i'm curious you've been streaming now
for like over over a year now
what are some of the
fun streams that you've done like the
unique ones that have already stood out
in your yeah i'm curious because i want
to know what kind of streams you get
what is your favorite content that you
produce content
quote unquote content um i did a staring
contest one time wait how does that wait
what you did yeah so i was at a friend's
house that i hadn't seen in a while and
i really couldn't reschedule hanging out
with her so um i went to the bathroom in
the morning
and um i took my laptop i took my usb
microphone i pulled myself real up close
to the camera and i did a staring
contest with everyone and um
it did really well actually there were a
lot of people doing that how long did
that last about an hour but see it kind
of devolved it wasn't entirely only me
staring at everyone in the beginning i
started off like being just kind of like
sleepy and quite frankly a bit rude um
to everyone in chat i feel a little bad
about that but then afterwards we got
onto some fun content quote unquote
content i actually went and um i found
some some old uh copy pastas to try and
read without cracking a smile um on the
stream
and um i got through i got through shrek
i got through um
actually the answer
yeah yeah um the one that got me though
i don't know if you guys know this one
of all the ones to get me the one that
got me was uh club penguin is kill oh
yeah i love that one i love that one
what is that one
i think you got it can you perform this
if i could pull it up on my phone i'd
i'd do it for you
but
we need to get it up
is it a copy pasta is it a meme what is
it yes it's like a tweet actually oh
okay okay
thanks
a live reading yeah a live reading of
club penguin and i'll try not to laugh
this time because
it actually wasn't the copy pasta itself
that got me to laugh it was chat yeah um
okay
he's gonna go into the void now he's
gonna like cut yeah
all right here's my live reading
here we go
this is from sergeant archdoornand who
left um
a tweet
about the club penguin after it shut
down
um apolgi for bad english
where were you when club penguin died
i was at house eating dorito
when phone ring
club penguin is killed
why is it funny
what is what is it about it that is so
funny it's the doritos it's the doritos
it's a single direction
[Music]
the saddest part is the part that got me
to laugh was just everyone in chat
saying no
that was what got me
you know i was gonna add some like epic
music as you were reading that or
something man
thank you very much magic reading
absolutely
it's the first copy past we've had on
trash taking hell yeah yeah
if you guys don't get in trouble for
this
oh no no
i sneak back the phone through the void
there we go it's like how do you think
up of ideas for streams because one
thing about stream is that how often do
you stream every week uh it depends i
really started to try and get more into
five streams a week when i was focusing
more on music but october has been
really busy because you know it's
halloween it's my favorite month i am
the grim reaper so i've been i've been
doing like seven to nine a week um
[Music]
seven to nine streams a week yes is that
a stream every day uh yeah you know
there's seven days in a week
well sometimes i'll clump them together
because the way i see it is if i can get
one day off where i don't have to worry
about anything that's great but if i can
like do two streams at once in a day
it's like i can get all of it and you're
doing music on top of this as well
what the [ __ ]
it's fun well i mean i like streaming a
lot it's great but my my passion at the
end of all of it is music and i can't i
can't resist doing that um of course
how do you think up of nine different
streams a week does it like
do you like sometimes is it easy do you
have like an idea that you fall back on
or does it get like tiring having to
think up of like variety streams
different things i think john can only
think of nine videos a year right yeah
yeah yeah i was gonna say yeah
that's like [ __ ]
interestingly enough it's a situation
where um i keep thinking of things that
i want to stream in that week and then i
end up clogging up my schedule so
there's just a lot of games that i want
to play there was a situation where i
ordered the wii u four different times i
finally got it um yeah so let me explain
let me explain how this went down so i
ordered a wii u um while i was in
america uh so that i could have it
shipped and then i could take it back
with me uh to japan so that i could play
earthbound because i've been really
trying to do an earthbound playthrough
um on stream and so i got that but it
arrived too late um in america i was
already in japan so then i ordered one
to come to japan a japanese one i
thought you could change the language to
english you cannot
so that didn't work out um everything i
read on the internet was a lie about
that so um i gave to a friend um and
then after that i ordered one on ebay
from america they tried to deliver it to
my house after one failed delivery
attempt sent it back to america uh so
finally finally i got one off of amazon
that they were willing to ship to japan
and it arrived
and finally i have a freaking wii u
so um
yeah but back to the question there are
too many things that i want to do um i
feel like i'm not failing we're
earthbound on the stream oh but i gotta
finish playing doom eternal oh but
there's other there's this other game
that i want to play wait a minute we
just got permission for this i want to
stream this before anyone else kind of
thing you know um two different people
want to do a collaboration well i always
love doing collabs with people that
reach out to me so let's do it
everyone's been asking for a minecraft
stream let's play minecraft you know i
haven't done a chatting stream in a
while i want to let everyone know what's
going on i want to talk about my new
song that just came out i mean i haven't
done an asmr stream in a while it's just
all these ideas come to me and i'm like
man i wish i could be this full of ideas
man
i mean it's a bit of a stressor though i
really should learn to spread things out
more often i just get real excited about
i have an idea let's do it now
well it sounds like you've gone from
like three part-time jobs to working
three part-time jobs in one job so yeah
it does feel like that when you're on
charge your own schedule it gets to be
like that sometimes yeah i i saw that
you got uh you are doing a convention
appearance yeah oh yeah yeah is it is it
is it almost strange doing it virtually
as opposed to irl
that's a good question um
it does feel a little unreal sometimes
but then once i see like all the fans
gathering together yeah it all starts to
settle and i'm like oh man this is a
real thing wow people really like us and
uh yeah i think once we started like for
example doing the um the fan expo panels
that was when i kind of started to
realize like how many really how many
fans we have and uh it made it all super
real for me so that was do i feel a bit
sad that you can never interact with
them directly is that yeah yeah because
to us that's like a big part of us going
to conventions right do you yeah
i mean i hope that there is a day where
that kind of thing can happen i mean i
have a friend i've talked about on the
stream before milky queen she does
things like that um going to conventions
and can actually like meet full body in
front of like a green screen in front of
um in front of the fans and like they
can touch the screen and like high-five
her and stuff like that and that's
something i'd love to do i don't really
know if if that's something that holo
can accomplish right now but i think it
would be amazing
technology these days man
basically facebook just make youtubers
because that will like that will make
the interest just like 10 times more
yeah oh for sure
yeah well interestingly enough we did do
a vr stream um myself and all of the
myth myth girls we did uh for our
anniversary we all got into vr chat and
um we actually all bought the suits to
like track our movements and stuff like
that and
we went in as like small versions of
ourselves i saw this yeah yeah yeah that
was so fun and it just it made me want
to meet with the others even more so
that we can really fully debut someday
in 3d
is it weird wearing like the full
tracking suit
what what is the four tracking suits is
it the one like the mocap is it the
actual mocap suits or is it the one
where you it's like on the i think it's
like i think it's like one it's like two
on the hands two on the feet and then
like one on your waist yeah yeah yeah
yeah you track your waist movements i
had a little too much fun with that
though with all the traffic
just moving around maybe a little too
much probably could have dialed it back
a bit but i was so excited to like be in
a 3d space able to move with my friends
you know